congratulations on the film it's
incredibly intense I'm still kind of
like slightly unspooling my nerves
good that's why I wanted your anxiety it
makes me strong yeah have you had a
chance to have a full audience yet I
have I've seen about nine times I might
be slightly biased but I love it
I know in fact that the best audience I
saw what I went to the premiere of
course and my mom and my family and also
and I they were watching it and
screaming and sharing so that that was
my favorite and I heard like you're kind
of a history nut but Sanders didn't know
this when he know the project it was
pure good fortune know he phoned me up
and he said I have this idea it's
loosely based on my grandfather it's
inspired by the stories that he told me
I am it's all set in World War one I
want to call rate at you interest is not
really first of all right with Sam
Mendes yes Avengers oh my god I was so
excited I did a little dance it wasn't
very cool I am so I really kind of like
I mean see to be young women to be asked
to write a war film of the scale is
surreal
I wouldn't happen without someone like
Sam who's very kind of like thinks at
the box
I am so right we dream project and then
the only spanner in the works was the
end of that call he went oh by the way
it's all gonna be one short they hung up
I was like no no that's gonna be hard
maybe impossible so that that was I knew
I was getting into and were you able to
kind of bring in your own kind of family
history well yeah I don't have any and
none of my immediate family fought or
are served in the war I am so I I don't
have necessarily at that kind of I don't
have as a person occasion as Sam but my
grandfather was also a history not and
Glasgow where I grew up you know I'm an
entire generation of men were wiped out
there so much the women were working in
the shipbuilding industry sighs that's
how devastated class scores and that
profoundly affect my grandfather I'm and
and his family and so he passed on to me
at this real love for history but also
how important history is so that you can
learn to not keep making these horrific
catastrophic mistakes of people and so
to me it was very personal but not with
and necessary
a family connection that way and how
important was you to because I heard you
entered northern France too late yeah
like go to it the places where these
battles catchy yeah actually I mean it
was invaluable and absolutely harrowing
I went to northern France because I
wanted to take the exact same journey
that the boys were gonna take in the
film I'm I wanted to as the writer
understand the landscape understand the
distances because it's a movie in real
time you're actually thinking about
distances covered which you should fix
the writers this is not on your mind I'm
so I went there and I walked and I went
round tip Val and the song I went to the
lock in the GAR crater and I mean I
don't know if you've ever seen the Loch
Negara crater but it's an explosion a
mine site and it looks like an asteroid
is so unbelievably large and around it
is the there are the ages and the names
of the men that died that day and one of
them was 15 and and you know you drive
down a mile allured in France and
there's five symmetries per mile near
enough and so I suppose what was really
striking to me was the cost in human
life thousands of men died for inches
and to me to understand that so that I
could then funnel that through the
script to understand what the characters
would go through was invaluable
hmm and I think like the first world war
is like the first war that so many kind
of great prose and it's the first war
really untraced it's the first war where
it's not all soldiers or if I think I'm
every man we swept into it really and
women too so you you have plumbers and
accountants and lawyers we also have
artists and poets and so out of the war
is born from this great horror
incredible poetry and credible
literature and amazing artwork I mean
Paul Nash here that we never simply were
huge inspirations for me and the writing
of the script